hello pollination my name is herion
converse on my wondrous believe and I
believe that much parents will solve all
of the world's major problems so element
your journey today I'm going to talk
about the seven ways that you can stop
negative so one of the questions I get
asked a lot of entrepreneurs and how do
I stay positive
how do I avoid going into the negative
zone you know Logan entrepreneurs really
hard to get my business going to so many
pain struggles that people don't believe
in me and always we told the quick we'll
do the safe smart thing and get a job I
always say positive how do i stair that
negative territory and so today I'm
going to share with you my seven ways
now to avoid negative thinking and it's
living a background on myself to I'm
currently voices it in the microwave one
of the things that I've challenged
myself is to restructure my thinking Oh
Rama there is no such thing as a bad I'm
trying to really embody that there's no
such thing as a bad day and I'm going to
share with you how I'm fixing that how
I'm believe in that that will hopefully
help you along your path of what your
anger so step number one is capture
yourself this design see where the
harvest part we have is no more meaning
it's just default run autopilot mode
we're constantly just in survival we'll
just try to put out fires and we don't
even catch the negative thoughts that we
have we just feel and I think that's the
first biggest challenge is being the
stuff outside whether that's you
yourself examining your day whether you
in the morning that's yourself how
you're feeling or how you felt yesterday
or taking a break
launching a break in the afternoon or
evening reflecting back a lot of people
a lot of entrence with journal
stochastic about how the day is done and
just reflect like was it India today
that I have negative spots was I mean
positive today right like any goal that
you have the more that you can track it
and measured the more likely you're
going to make progress so what's your
method of tracking whether you have
negatives a or not because if you cannot
catch yourself is a moment of being
negative then it's going to be hard for
you to change the behavior so whether
it's journaling whether it's taking time
out at specific parts to see if you're
being negative whether it's working with
somebody and saying hey these catcher be
negative let me know having some kind of
form of tracking so you're not just
always an autopilot mode and you know
exactly being negative once you figure
that out since number two is turkey-
different into how questions is one of
my favorite exercises if there's a
negative father who has something I
can't do this because you're so upset
because turns into a house wash turns to
a house can align or turn into a
gratitude stick so as an example if you
are upset that somebody's often has some
major success and you read about their
file and they have the same ID as you
did and you know they went to Harvard
and you didn't blame it on not going
university then you can ask yourself
instead of it as complaining the Buzzbee
negative turn it into a how question how
can I succeed despite their inner harbor
how can I succeed despite not having the
education of the one you're right
parents direct connections whatever it
is if you're blaming the world on right
how can I succeed is by asking about how
to question takes your negative
situation and turns it into something
positive the resource lists into the
resourceful right they're thinking about
how do we make this amazing thing happen
now out of this negative situation so as
long as you've seen is this negative
situation all these limiting beliefs
stealing the negative states but if you
sir actually selves how do i atopic
you're forcing your brain to think in a
positive ways you fortunately bring
themselves a problem and when you do
that in the doors of opportunity the
gratitude kind of thing is maybe upset
about you know the elevator music you
know I'm stuck in this elevator and I'm
waiting forever for this elevated
economy you're stuck in traffic or
there's something that does find your
control for me the thing that really
helps is just thinking about gratitude
so turn your expectations and
appreciation so it's pretty impressive
is this magical box that will take me
from the ground for the 20th floor I
don't have a lot of stairs and yeah
absolutely mixed with 45 seconds here at
the corner not in the world
so just shifting perspective again it's
such a passion
you got a caption no caption is being
negative you can't catch me I'm gonna
fix it but you catch it then turned into
a house of questions or just showing
appreciation and gratitude instead of
false expectations it really helped
reframe the situation September 3 is
create a better environment what am I
going to always when you try to change a
habit we're trying to get something that
is subconsciously you're always doing is
to make it part of your habit from your
days of the team and so if you're trying
to avoid being negative and think about
what's negative that's in your life you
know they're negative people that are in
your life and you try not to be around
them on a daily basis how does it can
you then drink more positivity into your
life on a participation what if your
morning repeat what is what I do every
day is I remind myself I'm trying to
work on that there's no such thing as a
bad day right so I'm having fun every
day one of the things that we do no such
thing is domestic try to remember we're
trying to feel yes remember something
that is important to me doctor my radar
again consistent remind myself of that
watching videos that are positive and
uplifting and how CEOs and entrepreneurs
asking 15 with all these negative
situations makes me feels more positive
and so designing your environment being
more routine so that you just fall into
that big lead
helps you start to restrain your thought
process so what I don't need is wake up
every day and not know what to do or
just follow the pattern that doesn't
support you that is intentional where
you spend some time is when adayla
coming afternoon the kind of what
residual to look like what is the
morning routine look what your means
that will allow you to be more positive
and eliminate negativity from my life
when I am faced then you take the other
tools like what does that my routine
look like with the tension created and
then every day like I want to wake up
every day this whole harder to not the
fixed person in the morning I just
followed my routine and I took the time
to pretty routine that supports that
kind of tip number four is pay attention
to the words that you use the words that
you use to describe situations will
often create the emotions that can
follow you throughout the day so watch
out for the words that you use
I'm personally working on us a lot so
when an annoying situation happens
whether it's a customer that's not happy
or I'm stuck in traffic you know you it
comes over like I can't believe this is
happening you see damage shoes drop the
f-bomb so many things that you can just
throw out there when something annoying
comes your way
but here's the thing emotion on a
chemical level can last anywhere from a
few seconds up to 90 seconds after that
it's often the labels that you put so
here's what I'm doing anytime something
really frustrating happens I label it up
it's a pickle and how do I solve it just
me saying that it's a pickle no matter
how bad it is
first of all cracks me up makes me laugh
and really at the end of it makes me
focus on how do I solve this thing and
really labeling it like that makes it
more manageable for me so what I want
you to do is pay attention to the words
that you use anytime something difficult
or annoying happens are you cursing are
you just physically just really turning
red and yelling at your dog I hope not
haha but it's important that you pay
attention to the words that use they
have a lot of power so next time
something annoying happens pay attention
to the words you use and change them
because once you change the words that
you use and the labels that you place on
your environment you can either become
more positive or more negative number
five as well defense I love most intense
when I go to almost when I'm kind of
figure out how to do something that I
don't know what to do with one of the
things that I always remind myself with
this negative positive thing is people
who have wayward situation like I much
really black women fortunate and so are
you think about where you're at in life
in fact if you have a computer you have
internet in to watch this video you're
ahead of most people in the world and
there's a lot of people some of your
heroes people you look up to who haven't
weighed less than when you are behind
right now surround myself of those
stories is just simply help meet the
message that they really differ a lot
less than I have now I can do it too
it's turn bullpen tactical right like
here's what you can do here's how we did
it but also motivation inspiration
because by following their stories just
by understanding that these people grow
up with such bad training situations
such four-wheelers and such limited
access to everything and made it as
buildings amazing businesses and has
this insane careers watching that helps
me and early on in my career before you
choose I was a blogger three books of
successful entrepreneurs and this is one
book that has couple pages for
entrepreneurs one every day just not
readable all just couple pages you have
time and we beautiful pages our person
and the Koenig is a motivational
Buddhist the inspirational loose as well
the tactics and now we're in your video
right by change because of people come
from enough and apathy look so much I
think I'm containing both this software
because people have done such amazing
things that has a deal with all of that
and they're in their life so having that
really helped me use the overcoming and
if you model success find the people who
got through what it is
would come out the other side both of
inspirations and some tactics up you
accomplish it boils since number six is
have accountability part I find it
really helpful when you're trying to
hold someone who have it have somebody
in your life who holds counter who says
hey you're not doing the thing is
because we're going to do as you ask me
to keep you accountable and you're not
feeling the same that you said what's
important to you
a finalist that's really important as we
will let ourselves down more than will
let other people down in such as
videomic and so if I look at my habit of
the business coaching is a bad day I
told me nuts with my wife's dating it's
mushy me complaining about something
negative I want you revive me this
building is about there and when she
does it to the door on your right yeah
you're very okay okay okay and try to
have a job but like that the process
it's catching the negativity in the
moment I told people my team your TDI
exit philosophy Lily it's not like
Google does this thing as a bad day I
supposed to my team to do this Vicki I'm
trying to build this happen no such
thing as a bad day if you find all of
that track I want you to catch and
there's people reactions like you're
always positive you'll complained about
that I know that's great you know my I'm
95 percent awesome but that five percent
when I might be complaining my PM says
sure my recruiting is a bad day so
having people to hold me accountable
when I forget when I laugh you know it's
okay that I say is important to me and
so some people may be afraid since
finding people in your life who know
will end up to you and say listen I'm
only doing this because you told me to
do this those kind of people I think
it's important when you when you
committed somebody else you have
somebody else to hold you accountable
you much collected and follow through
with anything and since number seven is
remember your one word I just put the
books about gun photography here one
word
kind of eccentric state stay book when
you know we can have a self-awareness to
know what it is is distinct for it right
with your one word is with the
multi-point core value is Eagle life
this is what your easy to stay on the
positive time because you want a
previous belief right I want to believe
while I believe myself including other
people more and you're one were to do
something positive right I've never had
summaries next one word with negatives
this is one mode with ships or chips or
destroy it's only something positive and
so it is easily to if asked to the
positive spot inside of you so if you're
designing your environment around the
commute believe right we're just
reminding yourself in reading your credo
on a daily basis or create an
environment that is your one word for
you but I want to lead to be everywhere
up my office and I walk into believe my
videos are our believes they always
believe the content I think is around
movies the things that I feed my head in
with is about believe it's important so
when you can design your environment
your routine and everything you absorb
on a daily basis around in one word the
most important core body that makes you
feel great is much more likely to take
on so that was my take on the seven ways
to stop your negative thinking I made
this movie because emmagan will not have
to do so this topic you'd like me to
cover in a future seven way video check
out the link in the description and you
can go and cast your vote I don't look
into what innovative this video which
one was the most important point for you
how are you going to stop more negative
thinking did I miss it
eight times ended want to add to the
list leave your thoughts in the comments
below and expectancy would you guys
deficit I also want to give a soup
chatter - Jay Leno's toast up thank you
so much for victims copy of my book your
one word doing the review and YouTube
channel share it on your Twitter account
as well I really really really
appreciate you support and I'm so glad
that with joy Franklin so thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you
hope you need to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love